[Music]
we live in a culture now that is really
enamored with the idea of technological
innovation and I would say that
certainly up until the last couple of
years but even in the aftermath of the
2016 election there has just been
widespread cultural admiration lianas
ation even daya fication of the founders
of Silicon Valley and the world that
they have built for us I think that's
misplaced faith in a lot of ways but I
think given the scale of the climate
crisis it's especially damning that's so
few of these people so few of these
founders and so few of our new
billionaires are really invested in the
climate crisis and in figuring out ways
to address it and I don't actually even
understand why that is to the extent
that these are people who want to see
themselves as world historical figures
who are driven in part by ego you'd
think they would see the existential
threat of climate change as an
incitement to action you could
theoretically invent a solution to this
problem and save the world and yet very
few of them are doing that instead they
seem focused on problems that are
arising from their own inventions so
they're very worried about runaway AI
for instance artificial intelligence but
climate change is a much bigger problem
than that climate change challenges
threatens to undermine the entire
infrastructure of our modern world all
of our political institutions all of our
social institutions our national
institutions everything is vulnerable to
the transformations of climate because
we all live within climate and I think
one perverse effect of our cult of
technology is that we're learning more
and more to think of what's happening on
our phones and on our screens as the
real world and to be less focused on the
impacts that are happening outside
outside our windows and in a in an awful
way I think that may train us for the
climate suffering that we're likely to
see over the next few decades but what I
would hope for is that more of these
figures really focused on what are
possible technological solutions and you
do see Bill Gates doing exactly that
he's made really significant investments
in negative emissions technologies and
is in fact behind the most exciting
research in that area which is quite
exciting it's a company called carbon
engineering led by a guy named David
Keith that has found that you can take
carbon out of the atmosphere at a cost
of about $100 a ton that would mean in
theory that we could completely
neutralize all global carbon emissions
at a cost of about three trillion
dollars a year which would mean that the
economy could continue just as it is our
agriculture could continue just as it is
our infrastructure our industry can
continue just as they are and we could
just completely suck out all of the
carbon that was being emitted for three
trillion dollars a year which sounds
like an enormous amount but there are
estimates that about how how much we
subsidize the fossil fuel business today
that run as high as five trillion
dollars a year in theory we could
redirect those subsidies to this
technology and solve the problem already
that's in theory there are huge
engineering problems we'd have to find a
way to a place to put the carbon which
would require the experts say a new
industry two or three times the size of
the oil and gas business right now
that's just to put the carbon back into
the ground but nevertheless there are
really promising technological paths
forward we've seen incredible progress
on green energy over the last 10-15
years much faster than anyone predicted
even if biggest advocates and we need to
continue doing that so while there are
places in the world now many places in
the world where renewables are cheaper
than dirty energy it's not true
everywhere and it's not true in the
places that need it in most parts of
China India sub-saharan Africa the more
that we invest in that technology the
more we can share that IP and allow
other countries in the world to develop
on much more carbon responsible paths so
there are great technological
opportunities for people who are focused
on solving the problem through
technology the problem is the most
powerful people who have decided are our
technological leaders just seem not all
that interested in this problem and I
think we really need to change those
minds because we we need that money we
need that we need that intellectual
power we need a cultural cachet focused
on this problem in fact we need
everything we can get this is really an
all-hands-on-deck problem and I don't
think we'll be able to address it
without technology so we need all those
people
[Music]